hi guys welcome to the simply learn live
session on the top 10 trending IT jobs
of 2020 so before we begin let's wait
for a few minutes while people join in
once again I'd like to welcome everyone
to this live session I would also like
to thank everyone joining in from
Facebook and YouTube so before we begin
I'd like to remind all of you that we
have a dedicated team here to answer
your questions so if you have any ask
away in the comments section below now
without further ado let's get started at
number 10 we have business intelligence
analyst a business intelligence analyst
is someone who transforms data into
insights so that they can deliver
business value now with the help of data
analytics data visualization and data
modeling they're able to identify trends
that can help organizations improve
processes and modernize now let's talk
about salary a business intelligence
analyst in the United States earns
approximately $70,000 per annum in India
the average salary of a business
intelligence analyst is approximately 6
lakh rupees per annum now let's talk
about the skills required to become a
business intelligence analyst first off
you need to be well-versed with sequel
programming it's a basic requirement for
analytical reporting and business
intelligence now whether it's to fetch
data from relational databases or to
perform data validation from a data
warehouse you'll also need to have an
understanding of data collection
management and understand the different
data sources and transaction
applications moreover you will also need
to have experience with business
intelligence tools like tableau and
power bi a good understanding of data
modelling is also important since it
provides a set of tools and techniques
that help you understand and analyze how
an organization can collect update and
store data now let's have a look at some
companies hiring business intelligence
analysts we have Amazon Standard
Chartered Tata Accenture just to name a
few
now another thing that can help you add
value to you yes you may is
certifications let's have a look at some
of them pertaining to this domain
firstly we have the certified business
intelligence professional pride by the
TD WI which is the transforming data
with intelligence then you have the
tableau desktop certified professional
then the IBM certified designer IBM
ignores analytics author version 11 and
simply learns own business analyst
master's program and simply learns own
business analyst master's program so now
that we're done with number 10 let's go
to number 9 blockchain developer a
blockchain developer designs implements
and supports a blockchain network they
create an optimized blockchain protocols
and they develop distributed
applications and smart contracts on the
blockchain network now let's have a look
at the salary of a blockchain developer
in the United States the average salary
of a blockchain developer is
approximately 72,000 dollars per annum
in India they paid approximately 4 lakh
rupees per annum so what are the skills
required to become a blockchain
developer let's find out firstly you
need to have experience with programming
languages this is important since most
block chains are created in languages
like Java C++ JavaScript Python and so
on you'll also need to have a basic
understanding of object-oriented
programming concepts because the concept
of classes that is the wrapping up of
data and functions into a single unit
called class on what block chains
functionally next you'll need to know
about flat and relational databases
which was the concept that blockchain
was born from you'll also need to know
about data structures like stacked
linked lists queue and so on this is
because blockchain is a backlink list of
blocks that hold transactions you will
also have to have some experience with
web app development now this opens up a
wide array of opportunities to create
web and mobile applications based on
blockchain technology and finally you
need to know about networking
since block chains work on the Internet
it's important that you're clear with
the important concepts regarding how
networks work how systems are able to
communicate with each other and so on
next we're going to have a look at some
certifications that can help you get the
role of a blockchain developer more
easily firstly you have the blockchain
for beginner certification provided by
the Linux Foundation IBM's blockchain
foundation for developer certification
course allows blockchain foundations in
use cases certification and simply
learns blockchain certification training
course now let's go to number 8 software
engineer a software engineer is an
individual who's involved in the design
development maintenance testing and
evaluation of
software they can use engineering
principles and programming languages to
build software developed videogames and
run network control systems now let's
talk about salary a software engineer in
the United States earns approximately
ninety two thousand dollars per annum in
India the average salary of a software
engineer is approximately rupees six
lakhs per annum so now that we're done
with that let's have a look at some of
the skills required to become a software
engineer first off you need to be
well-versed with programming you'll need
to have experience with languages like
Java Python c-sharp Ruby and so on next
you'll need to know about data
structures and algorithms this is really
important
since organizing the data with the help
of the right data structures and
algorithms can greatly help with
minimizing time and space then you need
to have experience with object-oriented
design with this you can plan a system
of interacting objects for the purpose
of solving a software problem with the
help of object-oriented designs for key
principles you'll also need to have an
understanding of databases and finally
you need to know the basics of
networking now since most applications
are web-based a good understanding of
networking and its concept since most
applications are now web-based a good
understanding of networking and its
concepts can go a long way for someone
planning to be a software engineer now
let's talk with the companies that are
currently hiring software engineers
there's Dell McAfee Google Phillips and
so much more now let's have a look at
some certifications firstly you have the
Microsoft Certified solutions developer
app builder certification then you have
the ACP certified development associate
certification and clouded us and cloud a
certified professional data engineer
certification now that we're done with
number eight let's go to number seven
cyber security engineer a cyber security
engineer is an individual who helps
businesses protect the computer and
networking systems from hackers and
cyberattacks
now they protect sensitive information
and ensure sensitive data bases are
protected from hackers and cyber
criminals now let's talk about salary
the average salary of a cyber security
engineer in the United States is
approximately 99 thousand dollars per
annum in India the cyber security
engineer
paid approximately six lakh rupees per
annum now let's have a look at the
skills required to become a cyber
security engineer first off
programming knowledge knowledge about
different programming languages like C
C++ C sharp Python Ruby and so on will
help you gauge the attack and severity
next you need to know how you can secure
your applications or websites using web
security and encryption you will also
need to have knowledge about security
testing and auditing you need to know
how to assess vulnerabilities and handle
them and how you can manage the network
you'll also need to have experience with
risk analysis and mitigation which is to
identify issues before they increase in
severity and think of potential
solutions for the issue and finally you
need to have experience with malware
detection and reversing now this will
help you stay proactive about problems
and ensure quick ways of handling them
now let's talk about the companies that
are currently hiring cyber security
engineers firstly we have GE healthcare
target Erickson Cisco and so on just to
name a few
now let's have a look at some of the
certifications for cyber security
engineers firstly we have the certified
ethical hacker certification the
computer hacking forensic investigator
certification the offensive security
certified professional certification and
the certified information systems
security professional certification so
now we're done with number 7 let's go to
number 6
DevOps engineer a DevOps engineer is an
individual who works with software
developers systems operators and other
IT staff to supervise code releases he
or she collaborates with both
development and the operation teams and
improves coordination by automating and
streamlining integration and deployment
now let's talk about the salary of a
DevOps engineer the average salary of a
DevOps engineer in the United States is
approximately in ninety nine thousand
dollars per annum in India the average
salary of a DevOps engineer is six lakh
rupees per annum next let's have a look
at some of the skills required by a
DevOps engineer
first off you need to have an
understanding of programming it uses
programming languages like Ruby Python
and JavaScript DevOps uses programming
languages like Ruby Python JavaScript
and so on for developing an automating
software then you'll need to understand
source control so this enables you to
track and manage changes to code it
provides a history of code development
and resolve conflicts when merging from
multiple sources you will also need to
have experience with continuous
integration with this developers can
integrate code into a shared repository
frequently repeated times a day
you'll also need to know about
infrastructure automation and knowledge
about cloud computing platforms like AWS
or Amazon Web Services Google cloud
platform and Microsoft Azure and finally
you need to have a firm understanding of
deployment automation and orchestration
now let's talk about some of the
companies that are currently hiring
DevOps engineers we have companies like
Adobe Boeing Microsoft ASAP Huawei just
name of you and now let's have a look at
some of the certifications that can help
you become a DevOps engineer firstly we
have the docker certified associate
certification the AWS certified DevOps
Engineer professional certification
Microsoft certified Azure DevOps
engineering expert certification and
simply learns DevOps engineer master's
program so now we've reached midway so
before we go into number 5 I have a
question for you guys what do you guys
think is at the top of this list let me
know your predictions in the live chat
so now onwards to number 5 Big Data
engineer a big data engineer helps
develop maintain test and evaluate Big
Data solutions within organizations a
Big Data engineer can help create
large-scale data processing systems
provide data warehousing solutions and
work with the latest database
technologies now let's talk about the
salary of a big data engineer the
average salary of a big data engineer in
the United States is approximately one
hundred and three thousand dollars per
annum in India the average salary of a
big data engineer is approximately seven
lakh rupees per annum
now let's have a look at some of the
skills required to become a big data
engineer firstly you need to have
experience in programming it is one of
the most important aspects of being a
big data engineer you need to have
experience in languages like Java C++
and Python next you need to have
in-depth knowledge about DBMS and sequel
this will help you understand how data
is managed and maintained in a database
you'll also need to know how to write
sequel queries for an our DBMS or a
relational database management system
you'll need to have knowledge about the
ETL process and warehousing tools you'll
need to know how you can construct and
use a data warehouse that can carry out
the ETL operations or the extract
transform load operations you need to
aggregate unstructured data from one or
more sources to analyze it for better
business another important thing that
you need to know about is operating
systems you need to know about Linux and
UNIX operating systems since they can
handle the demands for root access to
hardware and os functionality you'll
need to have experience with Hadoop
based technologies like MapReduce HBase
Pig and hive and you'll need to have
experience with real time processing
frameworks with the help of analytics
engines like spark for real-time data
processing and finally you need to have
experience with data mining and modeling
now let's talk about some of the
companies that are hiring big data
engineers we have Intel Amazon Visa
Walmart Labs LinkedIn and so much more
now let's have a look at some of the
certifications that can help you become
a big data engineer we have the CDP data
engineer certification the IBM certified
data architect big data certification
the Google cloud certified data engineer
certification and simply learns big data
engineer master's program now let's go
to number 4 full stack developer a full
stack developer is a web developer or an
engineer who works with both front and
back ends of an application or website
they can handle projects involving
databases user facing websites and
involve themselves in the planning phase
of projects now let's talk about the
salary of a full stack developer the
average salary of a full stack developer
in the United States
to mately 106 thousand dollars per annum
the average salary for a full-stack
developer in India is approximately
seven lakh rupees per annum now let's
have a look at some of the skills
required to become a full-stack
developer first off you need to have
experience with programming languages
you need to be efficient with languages
like PHP Java Python c-sharp and so on
next you need to have experience with
front-end technology knowledge about
HTML and CSS will provide you the basic
building blocks to design and develop
websites it also enables you to add
content and styles to your site you need
to have experience working with api's
and an understanding of databases and
how databases can be interacted with
knowledge about databases like my sequel
MongoDB radius Oracle and so on are very
important you must also be familiar with
how code can be structured how to store
and separate certain files and so on now
let's have a look at some of the
companies that are hiring full start
developers we have companies like Oracle
Apple Vimeo Siemens Deloitte and much
more and now let's have a look at some
of the certifications that can help you
become a full-stack developer firstly we
have the full stack developer caused by
EDX the advanced full stack developer
boot camp by udemy and simply learns
full stack web developer certification
and now let's go to the top three number
three is cloud architect a cloud
architect is responsible for managing
cloud computing architecture in an
organization he or she handles
everything to do with front-end
platforms servers storage delivery and
networks that are required in cloud
storage now let's talk about the salary
of a cloud architect the average salary
of a cloud architect in the United
States is approximately 107 thousand
dollars per annum the average salary of
a cloud architect in India is
approximately 16 lakh rupees per annum
so now let's have a look at some of the
skills required to become a cloud
architect first off as usual is
knowledge about programming languages
knowledge about Perl Python Ruby PHP
Java dotnet and so on can provide you
with the
to build deploy and manage applications
quickly then you need to know the basics
of networking since most of the work
that you'll be doing will be very
related knowledge about networking can
be really helpful knowledge of data
storage fundamentals are also really
important this provides you with
knowledge to determine which data
storage option to use and when knowledge
of cloud service platforms is also
really important
platforms like AWS Google cloud platform
and Microsoft Azure are what you're
going to base most of your work on being
experienced with them is really
important and finally you need to have
experience with cloud security this will
make sure that your data is secure and
only the authorized score is run and
ensuring that the right people are
allowed to run it
it also helps limit access to other
resources now let's talk about the
companies hiring cloud architects we
have companies like a Y Wipro IBM and
the Hewlett Packard Enterprise this is
just the tip of the iceberg when it
comes to companies that are hiring cloud
architects and finally let's have a look
at some of the certifications that can
help you become a cloud architect
firstly you have the Airblade Solutions
Architect certification the Google
certified professional cloud architect
certification the comptia cloud+
certification and simply learns cloud
architect master's program which
includes both AWS and Azure now let's go
to number two data scientist these are
individuals who wrangle big data while
gathering and analyzing large amounts of
structured and unstructured data their
role combines computer science and
statistics the analyze process and model
data and interpret results to create
plans for companies and organizations
now let's talk about the salary of a
data scientist the average salary of a
data scientist in the United States is
approximately 113 thousand dollars per
annum in India the salary of a data
scientist is approximately 10 lakh
rupees per annum now let's have a look
at some of the skills required to become
a data scientist firstly you need to
have programming knowledge programming
languages like our Python and SAS are
really important to perform data
analytics you also need to have
experience
statistics linear algebra and calculus
experience with data wrangling is also
really important with this you can
prepare data for further analysis
transforming and mapping raw data from
one form to another while prepping data
for instance now you will also need to
have experience with data visualization
with this you're able to communicate
findings from the data and leave the
exploration to a conclusion now you can
create a story from data and create a
comprehensive presentation you'll also
need to know about software engineering
with this you can analyze user
requirements and then design build and
test software applications you'll also
need to have experience with data
intuition that will help you guide how
you approach data now let's talk about
some of the companies hiring data
scientists you have organizations like
Twitter Intel apple Bank of America
Amazon and so much more now let's have a
look at some of the certifications that
can help you become a data scientist
firstly you have the certified analytics
professional certification the cloud or
a certified professional CCP data
engineer certification IBM's data
science professional certification and
simply launch data scientist master's
program so before we get to number one
let's have a look at some honorable
mentions
these are job roles that almost made the
list but just because they didn't make
it doesn't mean they deserve to be not
they are IID solutions architect IT
project manager and networking and cloud
administrator now let's go to number one
let's see how many of you got it right
number one is AI or machine learning
engineer a machine learning engineer
creates and maintains machine learning
solutions to solve business problems
optimizing them for performance and
scalability and helping reduce customer
churn run targeted marketing ads and
improve product experience let's talk
about the salary of a machine learning
engineer the average salary of a machine
learning engineer in the United States
is approximately 114 thousand dollars
per annum now this can go up to hundred
and fifty thousand dollars per annum in
India the average salary
machine learning engineer is
approximately eight lakh rupees per
annum now let's talk about the skills
required to become a machine learning
engineer first off you need to have
experience with probability statistics
linear algebra and calculus an
understanding of concepts like matrices
vectors sampling probability
distribution and so on
are really important then you need to
have programming skills you need to have
experience with Python or Java
JavaScript and C you also need to know
about data engineering you need to know
about data pre-processing the ETL
process and knowledge about databases
like sequel and no sequel you'll also
need to have experience with machine
learning algorithms like linear
regression logistic regression nave
based classifier decision tree and so on
and finally you need to be experienced
with machine learning frameworks now
this helps abstract complex parts of
machine learning and makes it available
to a large group of developers now for
the final time let's talk about the
companies hiring machine learning
engineers we have organizations like
Google uber Facebook Apple and so much
more
let's now also have a look at some of
the certifications that can help you
become a machine learning engineer we
have course satara's machine learning
certification casseras AI for everyone
certification EDX is artificial
intelligence certification and simply
learns artificial intelligence master's
program and there you go these are the
top 10 trending IT jobs in 2020 with
that we've reached the end of this video
do you agree with our list think we
missed anything important let us know in
the live chat or if you're watching
later in the comments below thank you
for joining the session don't forget to
subscribe to our Channel and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
you